[Musik]
keine blume entfaltet ihre schönheit in
einem derart gigantischen us start
jeden frühling tauchen abermilliarden
von blüten die niederlande in einen
rausch von farben so weit das auge
reicht
doch diese blume hat eine geheime
geschichte
ihrer schönheit verfielen armee
tagediebe ebenso wie steinreiche
herrscher ihre
zwiebeln wurden in gold aufgewogen
alle unglaublich kloster und
farbstellungen zeugen im frühen 17
jahrhundert eine ganze nation in ihren
bann
[Musik]
sie wurde zum objekt von haarsträubender
spekulation
[Musik]
die preise stiegen in astronomische
höhen
doch schon nach kurzer zeit stürzten
tausende ins unglück als die preise
plötzlich ins bodenlose fielen
es war die erste
spekulationsblase der weltgeschichte
helms
der toten
[Musik]
wenn niederlande februar 1637
die nachricht verbreitete sich wie ein
lauffeuer
[Musik]
zum ersten mal hatte eine tulpen auktion
nicht den erwarteten preis erzielt in
den letzten monaten waren die preise um
mehr als das hundertfache gestiegen als
doch jetzt wollte plötzlich keiner mehr
drücken kaufen alle wertpapiere waren
wertlos geworden
der traum vom reichtum dauerte nur kurz
er beruhte auf dem handel mit einer ware
von äußerst unbeständigem wert
dennoch hatte das tropenfieber weite
teile der niederländischen bevölkerung
erfasst alle wollten von der gier nach
den bunten blüten profitieren
doch jetzt war alles aus
[Musik]
besonders hart traf es jene die von
anfang an nur über geringe finanzielle
mittel verfügten
denn an der tollsten spekulation hatten
sich alle beteiligten
einfacher handwerker bedienstete
tagelöhner oder spieler
menschen die der müller adrian
[Musik]
es war verrückt eine richtige mann nie
eine echte
spekulationsblase es machte ja auch
wenig sinn auf den ewig steigendem preis
einer blume zu wetten
peter im gaga ist ökonom und analyst
einer internationalen grossbank ein
der ob die parallelen zwischen dem
tulpen fifa und dem geschehen an
aktuellen börsen sind nicht zu übersehen
damals wie heute wetten zu viele
menschen auf eine viel zu hohe
preisentwicklung
bleibt die frage ist wieso fallen wir
seit jahrhunderten immer auf denselben
mechanismus herein der britische
historiker mike dashboard dafür nur eine
mögliche erklärung
es geht etwas im menschlichen denken
dass uns davon abhält die wahrheit über
börsen blasen glauben zuweilen
an einer spekulationsblase beteiligen
sich die meisten wider besseres wissen
dieses phänomen wurde bei der thulb
money des frühen 17 jahrhunderts
erstmals sichtbar
holland nahm in der ersten hälfte des
17ten jahrhunderts eine absolute
ausnahmestellung in europa ein
während der 30 jährige krieg den rest
des kontinents verwüstete erlebten die
niederlande ihr goldenes zeitalter
es war die zeit der großen
niederländischen meister wie rembrandt
frans hals
[Musik]
und fair mehr
dank des überseehandels boomte die
wirtschaft in beispiellosem ausmaß
denn statt kostspieliger
königsherrschaft regierten in den
niederlanden bürger und adel über
autonome städte und provinzen
man muss sich klarmachen dass die
niederlande im full 17 jahrhundert etwas
ganz besonderes fahren es war das erste
land in europa mit moderner wirtschaft
und das reichste land europas dieser
reichtum beruhte auf handel es war das
erste land das umfangreiche
handelsbeziehungen mit dem fernen osten
und erhebt und von dort stammten die
meisten luxusgüter indem sie die profite
für sich behalten konnten wurden die
niederländischen händler außerordentlich
reich
der reichtum gibt zum größten teil in
den händen weniger aber auch für den
rest der bevölkerung war der
lebensstandard höher als anderswo in
euro für handwerker ebenso wie für
bedienstete wie an einer
[Musik]
die niederländischen händler hatten im
vorangegangenen jahrhundert die
reformation durchlaufen holland befand
sich unter einfluss einer ziemlich
extremen form des calvinismus dadurch
war jede offensichtliche
zurschaustellung von reichtum in verpönt
die reichen konnten ihren wohlstand nur
in einer form demonstrieren die auch
gott verherrlicht
daher stand die niederländische
leidenschaft für gärten
regierte schmuckstück der holländischen
gartenbaukunst war die tulpe eine
pflanze die aus dem fernen zentralasien
stammte
[Musik]
den kalten steppen und gebirgsregionen
kasachstan bis heute die wilden
vorfahren der holländischen zucht toll
war
[Musik]
sie sind etwas kleiner und zeigen viele
prächtige farbschattierungen von rot
über orange bis gehemmt
[Musik]
von zentralasien als gelangte die tulpe
zuerst in die türkei wo sie als vorbote
des frühlings besonders verehrt wurde
die blume kam in der zweiten hälfte des
16 jahrhunderts nach europa in den
gärten kaiser rudolfs des zweiten
gelangen die ersten nachzüchtungen
mit dem botaniker chevrolet cruze
erreichte die tulpe schließlich die
niederlande
[Musik]
an der universität leiden gründete lag
ließ auch clou sie es genannt den
blumengarten hortus academicus wo bis
heute die nachkommen von crusius ersten
zucht rücken zu bewundern sind
exquisite blume sollte ganz holland in
ihren bann ziehen
so auch den müller adrian müller
[Musik]
er spielte gerade eine runde trick truck
als ihm das lebhafte treiben im
hinterzimmer der gaststätte auffiel
[Musik]
diese menschen schienen mit etwas zu
handeln sonst wird etwas äußerst
wertvollen
[Musik]
sofort wurde klar dass hier ein reger
austausch von geldstücken und
tulpenzwiebeln stattfand
und jeder konnte mitmachen
adrian witterte er seine chance
[Musik]
wenn sie in harlem aufgewachsen sind und
müller waren und versucht haben auf der
grundlage ihres wissens über diesen
markt vorherzusagen was der zukünftige
preis bringen würde können sie sich
irgendwo
[Musik]
jede spekulative investition ist vom
wunsch getrieben möglichst hohe gewinne
zu machen das tulpen fieber war da keine
ausnahme
ungewöhnlich waren nur die bedingungen
unter denen diese handel stattfand
es war eine art von parallel wirtschaft
die damals unter handwerkern und bauern
entstand diese leute wussten nicht genau
wie man so etwas macht sie bildeten ihre
eigenen börsen wobei sie sich im
gasthaus traf der truppen handel fand in
eine bierdunst atmosphäre statt dadurch
ließen sich die leute wohl auf höhere
risiken und auf weniger seriöse
geschäfte ein
zuerst wurden die zwiebel gewohnt
der verkäufer schritt den gewünschten
preis auf eine schiefertafel und übergab
sie dem vorsitzenden
der dann schrieben die interessenten ihr
gebotenen service
[Musik]
der vorsitzende legte dann den
verkaufspreis fest der irgendwo zwischen
dem gewünschten preis und dem höchsten
gebot lag
[Musik]
adrian schlug zu er hatte soeben sein
letztes geld für eine kleine braune
zwiebel ausgegeben
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich beim investieren den ton
an und der rest der erde tat es ihm
gleich allein aufgrund der tatsache dass
diese person in ein bestimmtes vorhaben
investiert hat alle steckten ihr geld in
dieses projekt oft ohne zu wissen worum
es dabei geht
auch adrian hatte noch nie zuvor mit
tulpen zu tun gehabt geschweige denn
welche gesessen er wusste nur dass diese
zwiebeln immer begehrter worden
[Musik]
was sich in den hinterzimmern von
haarlem abspielte war der erste vorbote
einer gigantischen industrie
[Musik]
80 prozent aller weltweit verkauften
tulpen stammen heute aus den
niederlanden
im frühling über ziel bunte blumen
bender die landschaft bis zum horizont
weise
[Musik]
doch die blüten aus diesen
farbenprächtigen weiten werden holland
niemals verlassen die bunten streifen in
der landschaft sind felder felder zum
anbau von blumenzwiebeln
nachdem sie verblüht sind werden die
tulpenzwiebeln wie kartoffeln aus der
erde geholt gereinigt und sortiert
bei diesem vorgang werden die tochter
zwiebeln der tulpe von der mutter
zwiebel getrennt durch diese um
geschlechtliche form der vermehrung
werden zusätzliche zwiebeln für die
zucht gewonnen
[Musik]
auch in dem niederländischen gärten des
17ten jahrhunderts wurden die tulpen
nach der blüte aus der erde genommen
[Musik]
damit sollte verhindert werden dass sich
hühner oder anderes gefräßiges geht ihr
über die saftigen zwiebeln der luxus
pflanze hermachten
ein weiterer zweck der alljährlichen
zwiebel ernte war schon damals die
gewinnung von tochter zwiebeln um neue
identische exemplare einer bestimmten
sorte zu erhalten
[Musik]
allerdings erforderten die kleinen
tochter zwiebeln im umgang ein gewisses
geschick
[Musik]
keiner hatte bemerkt was eine da vor die
füße gefallen war ist
[Musik]
jetzt hielt sie ihre eigene kleine
zwiebel in händen aus der sich im
nächsten jahr gewiss eine blüte von
höchster schönheit entfallen würde
aber niemand sollte davon erfahren
alleine verpackte die unscheinbare
preziose sorgfältig und versteckte sie
in ihrer kammer
[Musik]
ihr chef sollte wohl behütet bleiben
auch adrian schätzte tulpenzwiebeln wenn
auch aus einem anderen grund
[Musik]
jetzt im sommer waren die preise
erheblich gestiegen
[Musik]
je mehr menschen sich an der spekulation
beteiligt war umso schneller kletterten
die preise adrian bot seine kleine
braune zwiebel zum kauf innerhalb
kürzester zeit hatte er einen schönen
schnitt gemacht
doch es kam darauf an in welcher art von
tulpen man investiert
[Musik]
heutige tulpen unterscheiden sich
erheblich von denen in den niederlanden
des 17 jahrhunderts sie waren damals
noch viel bunter und farbenprächtiger
der wert bemaß sich an den farben und
der zeichnung je feiner die zeichnung
einer tulpe umso begehrter
[Musik]
heute gibt es tulpen in extravaganten
farbstellungen und fantastischen mustern
partners
und auch viele der gefahren hat ihnen
die empfindlichen pflanzen ausgesetzt
sind haben sich im laufe der
jahrhunderte kaum verändert
[Musik]
doch es sind nicht nur einer schaffte
hausgenossen die den tulpenzwiebeln
schaden können
tief in den zellstrukturen der pflanze
verbirgt sich ein winziger feind plant
ein virus
[Musik]
heute sind diese viren gut erforscht
aber im 17 jahrhundert sagte sie für
viele überraschungen bei den tollsten
zustande denn das virus kann das
aussehen einer pflanze radikal verändern
sobald es in sie eingedrungen ist
die viren sind ja als organismen selbst
nicht lebensfähig
die können sich nur in der pflanze als
wirtszelle überhaupt vermehren
mal geht laimer der kamera machado ist
spezialistin für pflanzen wären
die viren sind darauf spezialisiert die
pflanzenzelle umzuprogrammieren
und dabei kommt es meistens dazu dass
das pflanzen eigene programm ein
bisschen durcheinander kommt
das kann bedeuten dass einige gene
stärker ausgebildet werden und die
anderen total abgeschaltet wenn sie das
auf die farbpigmente in der blüte
umlegen dann gibt es zellen in dem das
virus bewirkt dass die farbstoffe
synthese angekurbelt wird dann gibt es
diese dunkelroten streifen oder die
farbstoff synthese wird ausgeschaltet
und dann gibt es nur noch diese hellen
weißen streifen
oder weißen flecken die dann eben dieses
besondere muster ausmachen
pflanzen werden werden auf verschiedene
weisen übertragen
aber dieses spezielle tulip breaking
virus wird von blattläusen übertragen
eine platte aus saugt an einer
infizierten pflanze und überträgt es
dann auf eine gesunde da kann man sich
vorstellen wenn in einem feld viele
toten beieinander stehen wie schnell das
mit sich bringt dass das ganze feld
infiziert ist
für die tulpen pflanze selbst ist diese
virusinfektion mit der zeit eben liter
[Musik]
dies halte es das virus ein massives
problem in der toten sucht
und es muss händisch bekämpft werden
diese toten züchter patrouillieren durch
die felder um verräterisch aussehende
pflanzen zu entfernen und so eine
ausbreitung der krankheit zu verhindern
diese virusinfektion sorgte aber auch
für die extravagantesten tulpen des
17ten jahrhunderts die hochbegehrten
geplanten exemplare mit streifen und
gekräuselten rändern
um eine schöne blume hervorzubringen
braucht man eine zwiebel und die
seltenen die zwiebel umso höher ihr wert
aber wie könnte eine völlig neue und
einzigartige art von tulpenzwiebel den
preis eines stattlichen hauses erreichen
wie es in den niederlanden der fall war
das liegt an der fähigkeit der zwiebel
sich zu vermehren
[Musik]
die aussicht auf verdoppelung oder
verdreifachung des wertes einer pflanze
durch die ernte von tochter zwiebeln
beflügelte die preis fantasien
über die biologischen grundlagen dieser
reproduktion war aber noch kaum etwas
bekannt allerdings wurden die tulpen zu
dieser zeit bereits nach sorten
katalogisiert
[Musik]
die natur der zwiebel macht die tulpe zu
einem idealen handels objekt quality sie
kann monatelang außerhalb der erde
überleben
zwiebeln sind leicht zu transportieren
einfach aufzubewahren und brauchen wenig
pflege
eine tulpenzwiebel ist ein speicher
organ das tulpen und andere verwandte
gewächse eben anlegen um unwirkliche
zeiten zu überdauern
das kann eine lange trockenperiode sein
das kann aber auch eine sehr lange oder
kalte winter periode sein
eine gewisse zeit bei niedrigen
temperaturen ist sogar voraussetzung für
das erneute wachstum
[Musik]
als ersten danach licht wärme und
feuchtigkeit im richtigen verhältnis auf
sie einwirken treibt die zwiebel aus
[Musik]
und will in kurzer zeit entsteht eine im
vergleich zur größe der zwiebel riesige
pflanze
[Musik]
in der zweiten hälfte des jahres 1637
wurden für seltene geflammt tulpen
preise von mehr als 100 gulden pro
zwiebel erzielt das war der gegenwert
von vier fetten schweinen oder 500
kilogramm käse um möglichst extravagante
muster und farben zu erzeugen wurden die
abenteuerlichsten methoden angewandt
manche versuchte gar die blütenfarbe
durch einlegen der zwiebeln in rotwein
zu manipulieren
[Musik]
heute werden professionellere
zuchtmethoden angewendet der ausgang der
bemühungen ist allerdings immer noch
ungewiss
trotz genauer berechnungen mittels
computer kennen die züchter oft nicht
das ergebnis wenn sie verschiedene
sorten miteinander kreuzen
stattdessen werden mehrere varianten
kombiniert und später jene nachkommen
ausgesucht die besonders schön und
widerstandsfähig sind doch bis es soweit
ist es geduld gefragt
zum ersten mal blüht vergehen ja first
time
[Musik]
manchmal können die züchter erst ein
jahrzehnt nach der erstbesteigung die
qualität einer neuen sorte beurteilen
[Musik]
seit jahren durch die natur ihre
zwiebeln zwar leicht zu handeln und zu
transportieren
aber die zwiebel hat auch einen großen
nachteil der man merkt ihr nicht an wie
ihre entfaltete blüte später aussehen
wird
der kauf einer zwiebel war daher eine
sache des vertrauens was
vertrauen das oft genug missbraucht
wurde
der tulpen handel setzt ein gewisses
vertrauen voraus es ist aber für uns
schwer abzuschätzen die quellen sind da
eher dürftig wie viel die leute
tatsächlich von dem glaubten was man
ihnen erzählt
das geheimnis dass jede schulte bis zum
nächsten frühling in sich trägt hat
machte jede art von handel zum glück
spielen wohl
manche züchter versuchten durch penible
sortieren und katalogisieren die risiken
für böse überraschungen in grenzen zu
halten
nicht auszudenken wenn ein missgeschick
die sortierten zwiebeln durcheinander
brachte
[Musik]
even mit patchwork selbst bei bester
organisation gibt immer ein restrisiko
[Musik]
da machst die wertvollsten exemplare
waren durch das tulpen virus infiziert
doch diese veränderung war für die
tulpen händler im zwiebel stadium
unmöglich zu erkennen
der umstand dass die pflanze infiziert
ist macht es sehr schwer vorherzusagen
was geschieht wenn sie das nächste mal
will sie können wir eine dieser
unglaublich wertvollen ge flammten toten
werden oder eben nicht
der zufall spielt eine große rolle bei
diesen transaktionen was sie für eine
gewisse art von geschäftemachern noch
attraktiver macht
[Musik]
denn vertrauen aufzubauen wir nutzen die
händler die meisterliche niederländische
malerei auf eine neue rat
eine der erstaunlichsten dinge aus den
niederlanden der 1600 30er jahre waren
die tulpen sicher diese bücher wurden
oft im auftrag reicher tulpen händler
angefertigt sie bestellten bei künstlern
darstellungen der tulpen aus ihrem
sortiment
heute sind tulpen bücher unsere
wichtigste quelle dafür wie die
begehrtesten variationen aus gesehen
haben oder wie sich die künstler
vorgestellt hatten
[Musik]
diese bilder zeigen drücken von
unglaublicher exotischer finesse aber
man musste eben glauben dass die person
die einem das bild zeigte auch der
besitzer der entsprechenden zwiebel war
aber selbst dann gibt viel raum für
täuschung
[Musik]
neben den spektakulären darstellungen
über traf man sich mit möglichst
distinguiert klingenden bezeichnungen
oder ruth van leiden
[Musik]
man kann mit recht sagen dass die tulpen
bücher eine frühe form der werbung war
die bücher wurden als reklame medium
eingesetzt
wie ein katalog um leute zu überzeugen
mancher der händler hatte noch nie in
seinem leben eine echte blühende tulpen
gesehen auch adrian studierte gebannt
die meisterhaften darstellungen
[Musik]
300 jahre später funktioniert der tulpen
handel natürlich ganz anders an keinem
ort der welt werden heute so viele
tulpen gehandelt wie am blumenmarkt von
als leer die halle ist so groß wie
mehrere fußballfelder
milliarden von pflanzen werden hier im
jahr durch geschlossen die verladehalle
arbeitet wie eine perfekt
synchronisierte logistik maschine den
schnittblumen sind eine extrem schnell
verderbliche ware
[Musik]
die blütezeit von tulpen dauert nur
einige wochen im frühjahr texten um die
erntezeit auszudehnen werden
schnittblumen in glashäusern gezogen
dort können sie kontrolliert in mehreren
etappen zur blüte gebracht werden so
wird die tulpen saison erheblich
verlängert
online handels prozess zu beschleunigen
wird auf den brunnen börsen die als mehr
nach dem prinzip der holländischen
auktion versteigert
dabei wird von einem festgesetzten
höchstpreis heruntergezählt
der zeitpunkt des bebens ist entscheidet
bietet man so voll ist der preis
möglicherweise zu hoch wartet man zu
lange schnappt einem ein anderer die
ware vor der nase weg politik
der handel hier beruht auf tatsächlich
existierenden blume geld und ware
wechseln zeitgleich vor ort dem besitzer
ein echter spotmarkt und genau das ist
der unterschied zu den handels methoden
die sich im herbst 1636 verbreiteten
[Musik]
und dafür ist der wachstumszyklus der
pflanze verantwortlich
[Musik]
im herbst müssen die tulpenzwiebeln in
die erde gesetzt werden damit sie im
frühling wieder blühen können
man legt sie besonderen wert auf das
engagement der verschiedenen sorten und
farbstellungen
das setzt allerdings voraus dass die
zwiebeln korrekt sortiert wurden und
nicht durcheinander gekommen waren
auch hier alles geheime zwiebel war es
jetzt zeit wieder unter die erde zu
kommen
[Musik]
eine tulpenzwiebel kann auch im topf
blühend wenn sie ähnlichen bedingungen
wie im freien ausgesetzt ist
[Musik]
entscheidend ist dass sie über den
winter eine kältephase durchläuft in
annes ungeheizte stube dürfte das kein
problem gewesen sein
[Musik]
tulpen blühen ein zwei wochen im
frühling
danach können ihre zwiebeln ausgegraben
werden und als wahre einige monat lang
gehandelt werden
über den winter müssen sie wieder in die
erde vom sterben sie
jede art von handel mit den zwiebeln im
herbst und winter war naturgemäß ein
geschäft in der zukunft
die zwiebeln wurden geliefert wenn sie
im juni wieder aus dem boden kamen
die tulpen händler saßen also im winter
ohne ware da um auch diese phase zu
nutzen er fanden sie eine neue art des
handels
für leute die mit dem zwiebel handel
geld verdienen ist die aussicht nur ein
paar wochen im jahr geschäfte machen zu
können wenig verlockend die logische
antwort darauf war mit den besitz
rechten einer zwiebel zu handeln
die art wie die niederländer das
umsetzten ist faszinierend sie erfanden
etwas das wir heute termingeschäft
nennen
die preise der zwiebeln selbst bewegten
sich nicht so stark die preise bei
termingeschäften stiegen enorm und
entfernten sich immer mehr vom
kassapreis
[Musik]
das war der beginn einer neuen ära
man konnte jetzt auch mit dingen handeln
die man noch gar nicht besaß
[Musik]
man kaufte nicht die zwiebel selbst
sondern das recht sie zu einem
bestimmten preis zu erwerben wenn sie
wieder geerntet wird
und man bekam ein papier wonach diese
zwiebeln aus diesem garten einer
bestimmten person gehört und wenn man
das papier überreichte würde man die
ware erhalten
in kneipen hinterzimmern hatten die
niederländer mit ein paar federstrichen
und blättern papiere eine virtuelle form
des handels erfunden
um die abwesenheit des eigentlichen
handelsgut erträglicher zu machen konnte
man sich anhand der prächtigen
darstellungen ein bild machen während
die erworbene pflanze noch irgendwo in
der erde schlummerte
bis zum oktober waren das reine futures
mit terminen preisen
der käufer hatte das verlustrisiko
ebenso wie die gewinnchance
viele der für den handel verwendeten
papiere sind bis heute erhalten
[Musik]
anhand der historischen dokumente wird
nachvollziehbar wie schnell sich der
handel mit den wertpapieren von den
eigentlichen waren den tulpenzwiebeln
entkoppelte
als folge stiegen die preise in immer
absurdere höhen
die zwiebeln sind wie münzen für sie die
papiere wie bank nun sie haben keinerlei
interesse an den pflanzen mehr noch von
den wachsenden schulden ging eine gefahr
aus denn die papiere die den anspruch
auf eine zwiebel bekundeten wurden
fällig sobald die pflanze aus der erde
gezogen zu diesem zeitpunkt brauchte man
eine große summe geld es war viel besser
mit dem papier nur zu spekulieren und am
ende jemand anderen zahlen zu lassen der
handel wird dadurch immer schneller und
hektischer
[Musik]
den spekulanten war dabei klar dass sie
mit fantasiepreisen handelten dann aber
die versuchung immer noch einen nächsten
profit mitzunehmen war einfach zu groß
[Musik]
man nannte es den wind handel und das
zeigt schon das ausmaß der damaligen
unsicherheit darüber dass da nicht sein
könnte außer wind daran kann man
erkennen dass einige leute sehr wohl
wussten wie unsicher diese geschäfte mit
der zukunft eigentlich waren
das prinzip hat sich bis heute kaum
geändert wenn die preise steigen setzen
alle auf steigende preise
das funktioniert umso besser wenn der
wert den ein papier repräsentiert keine
entsprechung in der wirklichkeit hat
oder wenn ihn die meisten
marktteilnehmer nicht genau verstehen
[Musik]
zusätzlich angeheizt wurde die
spekulation durch die tatsache dass der
eintrittspreis in den markt im
verhältnis zu den gewinnmöglichkeiten
relativ gering war
die beteiligten waren in der regel sehr
an sie verpfändeten ihre besitztümer um
anzahlungen auf toten zu leisten sie
kauften einen schuldschein vom besitzer
der tour dabei war immer nur eine
anzahlung fällig 1 weber der seinen weg
stuhl für 25 gulden verpfändete konnte
den gegenwert von 25 gulden in tulpen
kaufen zahlt er aber nur zweieinhalb
gulden an er wusste aber dass er den
vollen betrag in der zukunft zahlen
musste die preise stiegen aber so stark
dass das niemanden abschreckte also
investierte jeder alles was er hatte in
so viele zwiebeln wie möglich und hoffte
dass er die 90 prozent restschuld
weitergeben konnte bevor die zwiebeln
wieder aus der erde genommen wurden
[Musik]
das wird erst zum problem wenn sich
niemand mehr findet der einen höheren
preis zu zahlen bereit ist dann bricht
panik aus und die preise fallen ins
bodenlose mit
der definition nach ist eine blase eine
situation in der ein preis eines
anlagegut sehr schnell steigt und dann
zusammenbricht
etwas ähnliches ist im zuge der us
immobilienblase im jahr 2007 geschehen
[Musik]
doch zwischen dezember 1636 und januar
1637 stiegen die tulpen preise noch
mitunter ins astronomische
kolster chroniken bezeugen den rasanten
preisanstieg die preise für viele sorten
verziehen oder verzwanzigfachen sich
innerhalb weniger wochen
das rief natürlich auch diebe auf dem
planung hieß
die wohlhabenden mussten ihre
blumenbeete mit alarmanlagen schützen
nachts gruben die wir die begehrtesten
zwiebeln aus um sie auf den markt zu
werfen und markit
oder sie besorgten sich die pflanzen für
die sie bereits schuld scheine
ausgegeben hatten
die teuerste tulpe war eine seite namens
semper augustus bereits in den jahren
vor dem tulpen fieber wurde ihre zwiebel
angeblich für 3000 gulden gehandelt doch
inzwischen war der preis auf 10000
gulden gestiegen um diesen preis bekam
man ein prächtiges anwesen in der
nobelsten gegend von amsterdam aber
niemand hatte sie jemals gesehen die
semper augustus ist ein interessanter
fall sie ist die berühmteste jener zeit
wurde aber offenbar niemals gehandelt
man kennt niemanden der die pflanze
gesehen hat und wir kennen auch den
namen des besitzers nicht wir wissen nur
dass eine chronik erwähnt die blume wäre
irgendwann verkauft worden
wie von vielen anderen sorten lagen den
händlern auch von der semper augustus
der immer fröhliche truppe lediglich
abbildungen vor
[Musik]
auch adrian bezahlte immens hohe beträge
nur für ein farbenfrohes versprechen auf
papier
[Musik]
man kann in einigen tulpen büchern
darstellungen der semper augustus finden
es ist aber sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
der maler die pflanze jemals wirklich
gesehen hat und mal ehrlich wenn man
diese tulpe mit einer anderen dieser
herrlich fein gezeichneten tulpenlinie
zeit vergleicht sieht man keinen
unterschied aber wen interessierte das
bei dem deal ging es um profit nicht um
eine tulpe gut möglich dass diese
augustus nur ein mythos war
allerdings war die semper augustus wie
alle der hochbegehrten fein gezeichneten
tulpen das ergebnis einer virusinfektion
und damit ein völliges zufallsprodukt
sehr theoretisch könnte auch die zwiebel
die ihn alles kalter kaffee narrte auf
den frühling wartet zu einer der
wertvollsten tulpen heranwachsende haben
vielleicht war sie schon eine reiche
frau und wusste davon noch nichts in der
fraport
wenn man zuwachs für steckt man seine
investierbaren also die echten
ressourcen in riskantere spekulative
projekte und technologien
oft verliert man dabei und hinterher
sieht es dann aus wie eine blase
oder man gewinnt
im januar 1637 wurden die anleger
langsam nervös die gefahr war dass man
zwar eine dieser schuldscheine besaß
aber nicht das kapital die 90 prozent
rest verpflichtungen zu bezahlen
das erzeugte eine heftige
handelsaktivität wir wissen aus den
quellen jener zeit und das in diesem
sogenannten wirtshaus kollegien manche
zwiebel 1 10 mal pro tag den besitzer
wechselten alle versuchten die
verbindlichkeiten an jemand anderen
loszuwerden das tut natürlich stark zur
dynamik des toten fiebers bei
manche wie adrian begannen bereits über
fallende preise nachzudenken
der könnte im sommer billig zwiebeln
kaufen und dann bei der übergabe den
jetzt stark erhöhten preis kassieren
doch die meisten hofften die schulden in
diese sich gestürzt hatten mit den
profiten durch weiter steigende preise
ausgleichen zu können sie konnten es
sich nicht leisten auszusteigen und
solange die anderen ähnlich agierten
sollten eigentlich alle profitieren
natürlich wird diese erwartung an einem
bestimmten punkt zur illusion
doch dieser zeitpunkt ist nicht leicht
zu erkennen wie find ich dachte die
tulpen spekulation in internen sei nur
ein trinkspiel dass die demoralisierung
der gesellschaft widerspiegelt das war
nicht ernst gemeint es wurde zwischen
leuten gemacht die sehr wenig vermögen
hatten und daher sehr große wetten
miteinander abschlossen ohne aussicht
auf weitere wetten
moderne börsen broker stehen immer noch
vor demselben problem wie die tulpen
händler des 17ten jahrhunderts
wann ist der richtige zeitpunkt für den
ausstieg
es ist ein extrem schmaler grat zwischen
maximalen gewinnen und katastrophalen
verlusten der wendepunkt es der moment
in dem die preise ihren höhepunkt
erreichen und kurz bevor der markt in
einen verkaufsraum verfällt ein moment
der extrem schwer vorhersehbar ist
[Musik]
die spekulationen im herbst und winter
1636 37 ihren höhepunkt erreichte war
sie ein reiner wettmarkt und kein echter
jahre anlagemarkt
dann kam der moment mit denen niemand
gerechnet hatte es
anfang februar 1637 fand eine option für
tulpenzwiebeln in einem wirtshaus stadt
und zum ersten mal gab niemand ein gebot
ab der auktionator senkte den preis aber
auch beim zweiten versuch boot nehmen
das war noch nie vorgekommen aber die
folgen waren allen teilnehmern der
aktion klar sie wussten dass etwas sehr
schlimmes geschah die nachfrage nach
tulpen war komplett zum erliegen
gekommen
in diesem moment würden tausende von
träumen zerstört die menschen waren
fassungslos und entsetzt schwankten
zwischen die plötzliche erkenntnis
verleugnung und unglauben der moment der
wahrheit hatte wie ein blitz
eingeschlagen
sie stürmten aus dem gasthaus
beschworene freunde zu verkaufen die
panik verbreitete sich und die preise
für tulpen vielen praktisch auf null
aus panik wird eine wilde flucht die wir
seither bei jeder spekulationsblase
gesehen haben
beschleunigt durch moderne
kommunikationsmittel kann eine platzen
der blase zu einem strudel werden der
privatvermögen planken industrien
währungen und volkswirtschaften aufsaugt
und das soziale gefüge unserer
zivilisation zerreißt
in zeitgenössischen publikationen wurden
die tulpen händler verspottet scharf
kritisiert und sogar mit affen
verglichen
diese bilder drücken die frustration und
wut der massen aus die sich betrogen
fühlten sie seitdem scheint sich nichts
geändert zu haben
das tropenfieber war die erste
spekulationsblase überhaupt im frühen 17
jahrhundert konnten die menschen nicht
wissen dass die blase sich nicht
unendlich ausdehnen kann so etwas war
nie zuvor geschehen die tatsache dass
die blase unausweichlich platzen würde
bei ihnen völlig unbekannte
oft nach dem platzen der schuldenblase
waren die niederländischen behörden
gezwungen eine regelung zu finden es
wurde wie so oft danach auch ein
schuldenschnitt verordnet
nachdem kleinanleger geschöpft
verzweifelt und frustriert waren könnten
die behörden eine revolution befürchtet
haben
[Musik]
lediglich zehn prozent die höhe der
anzahlung mussten bei fälligkeit eines
papiers beglichen werden manche
kontrakte wurden gleich für null und
nichtig erklärt
der grund dafür dass es keine
wirtschaftliche notlage gab war dass es
keine viel lokation von realen
investitionsmitteln gab
heute ist die finanzspekulation tief in
der gesellschaft verwurzelt
der knall einer platzenden blase wird
auf der ganzen welt widerhallen und die
gesamte gesellschaft erschüttern
[Applaus]
wir erleben heute immer noch genau
dieselbe art von spekulationsblasen und
trotzdem machen die menschen immer
dieselben fehler
adrian musste seinen traum vom reichtum
begraben und in seinem beruf als müller
zurückkehren
[Musik]
und auf dem fensterbrett des
dienstmädchens eine blüte eine
extravagant geflammt olpe
nur wenige wochen zuvor hätte diese
pflanze sie zu einer reichen frau
gemacht die
doch jetzt was sie einfach wieder was
sie schon immer war eine wunderschöne
blume und ein symbol für den frühling
[Musik]